when i was a kid i always played with
legos i built cars planes
motorbikes
but now
i built an arm
[Music]
meet david aguilar
my name is david aguilar i am from
andorra and i'm 18 years old when david
was born his right arm hadn't fully
developed this is the
my right arm well growing up it was
quite annoying because i received a lot
of commentaries like oh you don't have a
hand or something like that and while
some would see this as a disadvantage
david is just a regular kid he likes edm
he goes by the name hand solo get it
he has an embarrassing dad
[Music]
he goes to school this is my school
and he can open doors with his lego arm
so
cool
growing up he was obsessed with lego so
much so he wanted to make it a part of
him
literally i built my first prosthetic
arm when i was nine years old and i
built it around my hand it started being
a boat
unfortunately the lego bricks weren't
strong enough and it wasn't for another
nine years till he would try again
this is mk1
this is lego technique it's like
the sophisticated part of lego i can do
push-ups with this thing so it's quite
strong when i first built the arm and it
was fully functional i went to the
mirror and i was like
that model the mk1 only took five days
to build of course like any good
inventor he got straight to work on an
upgrade
and this is mk2 it has a battery that
works like a biceps and it has this
fishing cable that ties up in here when
i fix this to my shoulder i can do this
and the arm closes i can't stop in the
middle
and move it by myself
[Music]
when i first brought this they're all
really amazed because how can somebody
create a hand out of legos
i was a normal guy and when i built the
the arm everyone was like you're awesome
you're you're really smart they told me
they are really proud to be to be my
friends it's amazing
[Music]
you